he's always professional he always knows
when his microphone is on he's Chris
Simms you did it again do I look and I
say soon as you walk in they're gonna
let you know the microphone is on I mean
everybody everybody lets me know and I
still messed it up but you guys got me
you know talking to the guys and I
started that you know man so that was a
live look in yes it is that's very live
looking yeah it can't be edited I'm
afraid of some of the people I might
have to hear from yeah I see now yeah
this is great all right so Chris Simms
pro football talk live co-host bleacher
report NFL analyst former NFL
quarterback we were just talking about
best Randy Moss says hands-down he's the
best receiver in the history of the game
ooh that's I could say this I think when
he was in his prime he's in that
conversation I think I think I would
take his prime over Jerry Rice I will
say that okay but I still think I'm
gonna give Jerry Rice the all time
because Jerry a lot like time Tom Brady
it's the overall consistency a greatness
that jumps out to me yeah okay year
three you know Jerry Rice might have
been the most explosive but year
thirteen he was still capable of doing
special things so Randy and his primary
things probably the most gifted receiver
we ever saw but I can't give him the
title over Jerry just because of the
longevity and consistency but explain
this to me yeah Brady's the best
quarterback of all time Oh
correct I you know I look at it
different ways he's certainly gonna have
you know the most decorated yes most
decorated not even close he's certainly
in that conversation you know who I
think the greatest quarterback of all
time is your dad definitely not but I
think Aaron Rodgers okay how can you be
the best quarterback right when you've
you don't have the best resume yes I
know he got one Super Bowl right I get
that but the last what makes him better
than Brady well I mean is it talent is
what that definitely talent Aaron
Rodgers the most talented quarterback to
ever play the sport for my money and I
and I I say that really confidently not
only because I've been around so many of
these Coryell Cunningham was so athletic
I know alway was so am I get it but see
this is where I go because guys like my
dad and Dan Marino and boomer sighs you
know I've been around they go and I've
never seen anybody like Aaron Rodgers
cuz yes he's not the fastest but he's
still pretty fast
I mean he was second and leading his
team in rushing two years ago if he
didn't pull his calf muscle he would
have led the team in rushing late in the
year
you know the offense like I've always
told you it's so basic it's all about
Aaron Rodgers but when I really break it
down I would just say this he is the
greatest arm in the history of the sport
he's got him and Dan Marino probably the
quickest release in the history of the
sport he's incredibly athletic right I
mean it's not Steve Young but it's close
to that and especially his ability to
sit in the pocket and jump around and
then we're talking about a guy who plays
a game like you know backyard football
but never throws interceptions
he's a gunslinger that's like the
greatest protector of the ball we've
ever seen so that's where I look at it
it's not a knock on Tom Brady or anybody
else I just look at him that's why I
would really go probably Rodgers Elway
would be my one too and I would probably
go Brady three Manning four and then
five would be Favre and Marino debate
right there when I'd probably give it to
Marino yeah I think Elwes the best
quarterback I think he you know here's a
baseball player you know he was athletic
to run his arm was as strong as anybody
who's ever played right he took three
teams to the Super Bowl that really had
no business going to the Super exactly
right
he got blame and then he didn't get
credit you know so when they went with
Terrell Davis he doesn't get credit
because it's Tyrell Davis team right
yeah yeah then he got blamed because he
took bad you know teams that were
inferior dry NFC and then he lost Super
Bowl totally agree totally agree it's
like the LeBron James conversation yeah
early yeah oh okay
yeah he lost three Super Bowls like you
said they were teams that weren't Super
Bowl caliber teams but he had the
ability to do things physically to get
them over the hump right and that's the
way I look at they're in Rogers it's
just his team's not even as good as some
of those Broncos teams his team like
I've been saying for the last three
years is a six and 10 football team that
he tricks us into every year we go I
think there's a Super Bowl favorite how
are the Patriots the favorites this year
because because there's so many reasons
I mean Bill Belichick that's the first
way you look at the roster I know it's
not the hizzy Finch got torched yes
the defense was horrible last year it
really was so yeah they've made some
improvements they did have injury
they're not the most talented team in
the AFC really a lot of the times
they've gone into Super Bowl those years
they haven't been the most talented team
but they're the most the most well
coached they're the most detailed they
execute the best and then they have a
quarterback who is like an extension of
the coaching staff still has a big-time
arm in his ability to execute and the
clutches as good as anybody we've ever
seen in the sport okay but Brady is
turning 41 today right when it's gonna
come crashing down at some point you'd
think yeah you know maybe he survives it
has a great year I thought if he won the
Super Bowl this past April he's gonna
retire I get you so he comes back what
is gonna be the fall-off like what will
happen where we go Brady's not he's the
leading candidate for MVP I know and I
understand that completely I think what
you'll see more than anything and is
gonna be jumpiness in the pocket right
that's where I think you're gonna start
to go oh he's getting old he's gonna
start feeling like seeing ghosts like Oh
ducking into the pocket and like
nobody's really there to kid him but
he's getting old and he's worried about
protecting his body that's when I think
you can start to look at it and go ooh
things are falling off like his arm is
not gonna fall off this is what the the
greatness of Brady he corrected his
throwing motion from 2010 11 12 and now
has made himself more of a power thrower
again to where he can throw the hundred
mile per hour fastball so I don't think
any of that I think it's all gonna be
about physical protection of the body is
he willing to stand in there and I think
when he starts to get sick of that or
get old you're gonna see him go down in
the pocket for no reason you know people
may be just an arm on him he's gonna go
I'm gonna go dad those are the little
things I would look for he's Chris Sims
Pro Football Talk Live co-host with Mike
Florio joining us here in the man cave
what do you take from the preseason game
last night I mean that's gonna matter
you know bigger picture okay yeah I mean
not a whole lot I look at games like
that I just want to look at some
individual players young guys free
agents I'm gonna go let me just look at
them the first thing I would look at is
both teams have great potential this
year they really do I think Baltimore's
in the hunt from one of the best teams
in the AFC when all said and done
Chicago is one of those teams in the NFC
that's like a lot more than I should I
think well but I get it because the
defense has been good
two years they keep Vic van geomat naggy
comes in we know he's creative they
signed weapons I think true Biscay has a
lot of potential the old lines good
they've been able to run the ball and
now they have some people to scare you
with the pass but I just look at players
more than anything I'll tell you who
jumped off to me more than anybody last
night rg3
I haven't been a big fan of rg3 and the
way he acts and carries himself
especially going back to the Redskins
days but I can't deny that last night he
looked good he threw a lot of good balls
made some good decisions through the
interception I mean the guy should have
caught it Yeah right and went right
through his hands and then of course
Lamar Jackson was the reason I was most
tuned in to the game but he acted like a
rookie should he did right we've all
lost like reality with what rookies used
to look like because of guys like Andrew
Luck cam right who've come in and just
set the world on fire this is an
extremely extremely raw player but you
could see he could sling it I mean he is
a very natural motion eye he can adjust
his arm angles his speed is legit but I
was worried last night he was gonna try
to prove I'm Johnny Pocket quarterback
look at what I've been doing in the NFL
and he actually did the opposite I know
where he dropped back it was like that
guy's not open I'm gonna show everybody
how fast I am and you'll know this
better than anybody but what I watched
is I wanted to see if he went through
progression yes he did he was like I'm
locked into that guy not open I'm
running exactly right and that's what
happens I think you know with younger
quarter yeah it definitely does it's one
of the other or you do the Marcus
Mariota where I like his first year
right would watch home and I go run
you're gonna run for 70 yards but he was
somebody was telling I'm all with
everyday stay in the pocket go through
your reads so he's trying to impress his
coaches and impress the public that I'm
a pocket passer so they'll he'll find
the right balance just like Mariota has
and they'll go from there but I still
think he's got tremendous potential yeah
we want we want to see him because we're
we don't want to see any more of Joe
Flacco yeah it feels like all right
we've seen this yeah you know that's the
old storyline eat let's bring a little
more Jackson he's gonna spice it up
there with with the Ravens also with
these rookie quarterback first rookie
quarterback who is going to play I think
Sam Donald and Josh Allen will start
further teams
Shallon story I do I think someone all
said
done I just think that yeah there's
gonna be some rawness there but I think
when they just see him out in the field
every day next to AJ McCarron the gun
him you're bigger than him damn you
throw and our jaws drop every day with
some of the throws you make you're so
athletic and I think they'll manage him
and start him at some at week one I
really do yeah I thought Rosen might be
the guy to get to start I know it
Rosen's the most ready like he could go
in and execute a real NFL offense and I
don't think have to be as managed as
much as maybe the other guys know but
they do have Sam Bradford they're gonna
take it slow
I can't imagine Arizona being very good
I really can't I look at their roster
and go oh it's down towards the bottom
of football and I'd say by week four or
five we see Josh Rosen in their worst
team in football's who I think they're
in that conversation Arizona yeah I do I
look at it like what are you hanging
your hat on the 36 year old receiver you
know Larry Fitzgerald first ballot
hall-of-famer he's the man but he's not
gonna like catch a slant and take it 70
yards it's all about in Johnson yeah
right so it's David Johnson you know
it's a quarterback that's been injured a
lot through his career the defense lost
honey badger
you know Chandler Jones sure he's great
Marcus Golden's coming off at ACL injury
you know Patrick Peterson's getting up
there in age there's just not a lot of
substance to that team I would probably
pick them as the worst team we also had
a conversation Colts maybe you know the
Colt Colts are up there I mean as far as
the roster Chris Ballard's just getting
his hands on that roster even the course
I'm gonna be bad III don't think they're
gonna be as bad as what their team maybe
is and as far as the rebuilding because
Andrew Luck I do think looks like he's
going in the right direction and he can
cover a whole lot of holes best
defensive back of all time modern era
right okay yes we had this discussion
the other day yeah my answer will
surprise you but give me the best
defensive back in the modern era I mean
Deion Sanders is the guy I go with okay
I he would be my number one you want to
hear the my other ones sure I would go D
on one I would go Darrelle Revis too and
then I would go probably Darryl Greene
three that would be my three yeah mine
is head read oh okay yeah okay yeah best
defensive back
that's defensive I think Henry
the best defensive back that I've ever
seen he was scary I hated I only played
against him once thank you yes you know
ads one of those guys too because he had
such great freedom and instincts he'd be
just lurking back there and he'd be
looking at you and you'd be like it
looks like they're gonna play cover two
they are playing cover two but what the
hell's that redoing that's C so he just
would jump plays and use his instincts
and it felt like you had to account for
Edie more than you did ray bruh Ray
Lewis yes I mean he was the guy that
scared me Ray was more of the just the
physical Intimidator where I mean my
experience playing Bray in that same
game Ray's not only just physically
elite as far as like taking people on
the whole and making big hits but his
mental game I mean there was a few times
in that game where I was getting ready
to say set hut and he's like they're
running right there so that's where Ray
really jumped off to me his leadership
his just brute physicality and then his
mental game was on point but who hits
you and then it feels like Ray would
probably hit you and then make noises
when he hit you yes or he would Jason
talk or say something like well he brake
he's he was I felt like he's sagging the
whole game I played against him he was
singing like his first game of the year
he was at football time he was singing
on field on the field he was a loose guy
in the field that's how you know that's
when you know that the best player in
the field is it's the guy that's the
most relaxed that's always smiling right
you know it's all you like you look at
Cam Newton and Aaron Rodgers sometimes
on Sunday and man they're smiling a lot
yeah cuz they're not worried about
anything in the world they know they're
the man out there and they're not
intimidated or scared about anything of
the game we see this every year where
there's two three four teams who move up
two three four teams who move down right
give me your team's that move off this
year yeah I think the the Bears like we
talked about are one of those teams I
look at the NFC in general is brutal
okay I think we all know that right
that's been I've heard it I feel like in
a lot of different places the Giants
would be another team you know they were
three and 13 last year I'd go watch out
for the Giants let's not forget they
learned the
best defenses in football two years ago
the coaching staff and everything that
went along with McAdoo last year was a
disaster they became dysfunctional I
think their roster is better than three
and thirteen they they're a Dark Horse
Super Bowl team hi they're scary I agree
I mean their offense could be the most
explosive offense in the sport and then
their defense has a lot of things you
like yeah defense should be good it
should be good corners probably a
question cuz he Eli Apple and his
shenanigans last year but yet they're
one team I look at you know who's gonna
disappoint us this year hmm I think if
mm I don't know who I would say was
gonna disappoint you the most I look at
like this I'll say this this is my
Jacksonville Jaguars are the best team
in the sport again they're the best
53-man roster you know my thoughts about
the quarterback so that knocks them down
a little bit but I do their have you
ever talked to Blake bortles face to
face no I have before like before I said
what I said last year welcome in Blake
bortles here - I know that's what stinks
about it because I know Blake such a
good guy and I don't want it to be
personal but those feels person I know
it's really not it's really I but you
said this the seventieth best way I did
there's 70th best quarterback yeah you
know people think that's crazy
and I understand they go well date what
to the AFC championship game and this is
one of the best defenses we've seen in
modern history I mean Talon wise it is
phenomenal it's not as crazy as
everybody thinks sometimes for a bad
quarterback to take a good team what
jerseys uh our man wearing out there
today old fridge he's got TiVo oh right
TiVo you mean the guy went to the final
eight and that wasn't an illegal next
year so people act like you know again
I'll go to the 2015 the team that won
the Superbowl had the worst quarterback
in the sport the thirty-fourth rated
quarterback was Peyton Manning with nine
touchdowns 17 interceptions if more
quarterbacks played that year he would
have been lower he would have been in
the 50s they won the Super Bowl with the
50th something best quarterback that
year it's not a knock on Peyton Manning
he's the man I get that but that year
that's what he was so it's not personal
against bortles bortles they have to
play a game to manage bortles and I what
I worry about with Jacksonville is you
see the way they play low scoring
physical type
where they gotta open up week one at the
new york giants the giants can play that
kind of game with them they're gonna be
like we're not physically intimidated
buddy we got a lot of big guys over here
to net week two is New England Patriots
uh-oh week threes the Tennessee Titans
so even though they're the most talented
team the way they play I could see them
this year fighting to get into the
playoffs nine and seven ten and six just
getting in and then being dangerous I
know that's maybe not the answer you
were quite looking for that San
Francisco people are selling them high
too high
that's my buddy Kyle Shanahan but I
think people are crazy today and they're
like Super Bowl odds are up they're like
nine wins you think is there over/under
I think they are definitely overrated
certainly how do the rams because the
Rams it feels like they're all in yeah
now if they got it they got to get darn
will do yeah but let's say they got
everybody right how great can the Rams
be yeah their roster is of course I
would say second in football right after
Jacksonville I think if you just look at
the complete roster it's always
interesting when you have to balance
personalities I'm not even gonna worry
about it out there because the two guys
out there McVeigh is an amazing social
skills personable guy he's gonna be able
to do it and then Wade Phillips on the
defensive side this is what he's famous
for his blend and personalities together
he's a personality himself so I think
that works and I do think they're gonna
be a dangerous football team certainly
and in the put in the Super Bowl
conversation not my number one in the
NFC though who's in the Saints I'm
picking the Saints to go to the Super
Bowl in the NFC this year I really am I
think with that old line Drew Brees
still playing good that offense was Sean
Payton and that defense has some things
that I like about it I would say watch
out for the Saints this year they're my
NFC NFC Superbowl pick AFC this is where
the AFC is I mean of course I want to
say New England I mean New England is
the team I look at New England and
Pittsburgh are certainly two teams I
look at if I had to do like a dark horse
team I don't even know it's dark horse
anymore the Chargers are a team that I
would have said I know the injuries hurt
but I think you know the Chargers the
Ravens they were two teams I looked at
last year I said oh if they sneak into
the AFC playoffs they can give the
it's a tough time both of those I'm with
you on the Chargers but hunter Henry
going down oh and Brett going down yeah
that hurts cuz Virat's birth special
man-to-man corner we know how much they
love the tight end and Phillip Rivers in
that offense so those are things yeah
that's certainly concern me if those
guys were playing those guys are healthy
eye I could see San Diego's the door I
can't really do good too
I think they can escape the Verret
injury I do think that the they can they
play a Seattle defense right the Seattle
scheme Gus Bradley's there so it's not a
ton of man-to-man
Hunter Henry hurts hunter Henry hurts
yeah because gage coming back he's not
it's not the game that we use this no
it's Phillip Rivers hall-of-famer
I would say no I would say he's an NFL
legend but at this point I would say no
you know everyone's gonna look at the
stats and do that everybody stats are
gonna be great steroids stats are gonna
be incredible when they argue they're
all there's there's gonna be so many
quarterbacks from this era because of
the rules because of just the explosion
of offensive ideas and schematics that's
yeah the numbers are gonna be off the
charts but I don't think I see Phillip
Rivers as a Hall of Famer I think he's
an NFL legend if he can have a run here
of maybe winning a Super Bowl get into
AFC championship games maybe that can
change my mind but I think he's on the
borderline kind of outside looking in
right now Ken Garoppolo be introduced as
2-time Super Bowl winning quarterback
now he could not no is your dad
introduced as a two-time Super Bowl
winning quarterback I think sometimes
people say that but I don't think he's
two rings I think he's really
appreciative of what Jeff Haas seller
did to get him that second ring and yes
he has two rings that he's very proud of
but I don't think he considers himself
two-time Super Bowl winner no not when
he was sitting on the sidelines with
crutches so does he wear that second
Super Bowl ring he doesn't wear either
one really I mean he's he's mr. humble
guy all the time I'm usually the one
that wants to go break him out and show
him off every now and then
let me go I want to show you these you
know if I have a friend over cuz that's
usually with friends asked for two I
I've never seen a Super Bowl ring and
I'm my dad's house I'm like oh come on
I'll show you one real quick i'm i'm
yeah i mean he's proud of him but you
ever take him to school
hey uh no oh when I was younger I think
I did taking school shown too I did I
did a little show-and-tell action yes I
did never wear it on a date no no I did
not no no I didn't need that no come on
who needs that yeah with that yeah but
you know Texas was paying you so well so
you always had money to one date well
nothing feels since paying me so I'll
leave you with this yeah the helmet rule
it how what are we gonna say about the
helmet rule at the end of the season
that is good for the game but it's very
annoying and how much it's officiated
like I just don't want it to go
overboard and I think it's gonna go over
but I heard you on the last thing
they're talking about like you know I
think early on they're gonna kind of set
that bar to go like don't cross it this
is where it is like if you do anything
close to it we're gonna call it our
intent is really hard to call exactly
but it was why I'm scared of it and I do
think we might see more penalties than
we'd like and that's annoying I just
want the hits that like Danny Trevathan
did of Davante Adams last year that
needs to be out of jail he should have
been suspended for them right and I
think he ended up getting suspended for
a game or two right those are the ones
that have to go that's just like piling
it on no need to just launch yourself
into somebody said other than that man
please NFL don't go crazy with this rule
I still want to see like physicality and
toughness is the number one thing in the
sport by the way who hits you when you
got hurt Thomas Davis and Chris Jenkins
they both had shoes Chris 23 Xion I'm
gonna throw a curl to the left and
Paulie bring out Thomas Davis hey yep
good old Thomas Davis yes so I had a
curl I was about to throw it somebody
flashed in front of it and then I felt
the pocket collapsing and I see Thomas
Davis running at me I'm gonna throw the
ball to bounce and as I hocked my arm to
throw it Chris Jenkins hit me from
behind and I couldn't get out of the way
of Thomas and he put his head right in
my you know sternum your spleen my
spleen
I had the which is no longer yes where
your spleen right like no where did they
where is it they took loan yeah I guess
they threw it in the trash I don't know
you get to keep no I know kind of yeah
put it in the jar let your kids take
that for show-and-tell you know they
went in laparoscopically and because
they thought they were gonna maybe
repair it but I from what I was told
that it was totally mangled and they had
to remove it so because I played I must
has formed a hematoma I kept playing and
I took some big shots in the game it was
the Carolina Panthers back in that day
with Julius Peppers and company and we
weren't playing well early in the year
so I was like me I'm not letting this
backup quarterback in here the hell with
all oh man and yeah of course that that
made it worse for did you lose
consciousness I called a play on a hard
- and Dan bending my left wing hard -
like I was gonna get the defense off
sighs because I thought I was sick of
Julius Peppers right so I'm like booty
five blue 85 set hard that's a good as
I'm doing this the curtains are going
down I'm going bullet e5 and I'm going
what the hell the the the defense is
becoming a black curtain and I start to
say it and thank God our left guard
jumped offside I did a good job of
inflecting my voice and he jumped
offside I had a handoff to the left to
Cadillac Williams and I had to take a
knee and knee cuz I just blacked out and
went in and got an IV and I came back
out and played and thought I led us on
the game-winning drive in the fourth
quarter and then they kicked the 59 yard
field goal to beat us but you blacked
out blacked out yes yeah
stupid stupid meathead from Jersey I
should have thrown in the towel long
before that we'll throw in the towel in
this interview Thanks I'm really man I'm
disciplines watch your language you got
to be professional I know I thought you
were coachable I'm where I am I'm
working out I just like you guys too
much that's the problem all right thank
you Chris great to see you buckets for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]